southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment spoke with rocky about
their senior focused initiatives
i'm sure you have tons of people asking
you medicare questions right now because
it is that time of the year so let's
start with the annual enrollment period
what is that period and what does it
mean to our seniors
well um so annual enrollment period it's
going on now now through uh december 7th
this is uh the time to you know
revisit your current
medicare plan or medicare advantage plan
um to see if there's any changes you
want to make so now is the time to look
at those things
see if your current plan is still
meeting your needs um and if any changes
need to be made then you know reaching
out to a broker to help you with making
those changes
and what about those those senior focus
initiatives that you guys have what
should older adults be looking for at
this moment for example we
are able to offer through optum our 24 7
telephone advisors so someone is always
there to kind of help assist and guide
where someone you know should go to get
further help
we also offer
virtual visits through our now clinic
that's 24 7.
there's also a program through dispatch
health it's almost like an urgent care
on wheels and they come to your home um
to evaluate you in the event you're not
able to go
and of course our all-time favorite is
our preventative care you know we're
really focused on making sure our
members stay healthy so that um they can
enjoy their life at home with their
family
absolutely and how do you find the the
medicare advantage plan that is actually
right for you because i know people have
options
right i mean i mean now i think in the
market there's so many plans available
so you know a person really should ask
themselves like okay what is it that i'm
looking for uh what are what's important
to me is my current primary care doctor
important are the specialists important
and you know if i do change my plan will
they continue to be covered
so
may thing like doctors that you're
currently seeing if you want to continue
to see them if you decide to switch to a
different plan you definitely want to
make sure that they're cut they're still
involved in that plan
medications that's a big thing i know a
lot of plans don't cover
medications so that's something to also
look for because medicare certain
medicare advantage plans can help cover
the cost of medication
um other things like eye exams glasses
so vision caring dental those are all
important
another thing that i know that people um
can have issues with this transportation
so looking to see if the plan has the
transportation benefit is really
important as well and with all of this
information there are three easy steps
that you want adults to remember right
yes yes the three easy steps that were
you're referring to is you know one
knowing your needs uh personalizing your
choices and then choosing your plan and
how can people get more information and
follow up on this topic with you guys
um
that's a very good question so you know
um as i said earlier the annual
enrollment is going on now ending
december 7. so it's really important to
make our choices um
now and pick our pick the
doctor that you want now um so calling
the number to talk to a licensed
salesperson that can help assist you
with your needs
perfect thank you so much dr carr
absolutely thank you for having me thank
you to southwest medical associates for
sponsoring that segment they have
locations across southern nevada you can
call that phone number on the screen
702-608-0964 to learn more or you can go
to their website at smalv.com
[Music]